Traduttore: Dario Napoli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che cosa straordinaria avere qui
degli esperti di musica.
Come esperti di musica?
Eh sì, perché ognuno di noi è musica.
Se riuscirò a farvi andare a casa oggi,
avendo questa consapevolezza
che la musica siamo noi,
gli esseri umani,
sarà un grandissimo risultato.
C'è un problema infatti nel linguaggio,
perché si dice spesso che per la musica
bisogna essere portati,
intendendo con questo che bisogna avere
un talento particolare.
Io invece leggo questa frase
in un altro modo.
“Essere portati”
vuol dire che c'è qualcuno
che ti deve portare alla musica.
Ed è per questo che io oggi sono qui.
Ho questa ambizione,
di fare in modo
che voi prendiate consapevolezza
del fatto di essere la musica.
Qualche anno fa avevo letto un libro
che si chiamava
“Disegnare con la parte destra
del cervello”
di Betty Edwards, molto interessante.
Ad un certo punto
c'era un piccolo raccontino
in cui si diceva che il cervello
è diviso in due parti:
la parte sinistra, che è quella razionale,
e che consente al navigatore
con sestante, bussola, carte nautiche,
spostandosi in isole che stanno, a volte,
a 2000 chilometri una dall'altra
nell'Oceano Pacifico,
di raggiungere l'altra isola
con un pensiero lineare o verticale,
quello della parte sinistra del cervello.
Dall'altra c'è invece l'abitante
di una di queste isole
che per andare nell'isola vicina,
a 2.000 chilometri,
che cosa ha necessità di fare?
Non ha a disposizione sestanti,
non ha a disposizione bussole.
Ma ha l'intuizione,
e prende altre informazioni,
quelle che passano
per la parte destra del cervello.
Lui - ecco che cosa c'è
di attinente con la musica,
ed è per questo che dico
che noi siamo la musica,
perché noi siamo esattamente strutturati
per fare della musica -
lui intuisce dov'è l'altra isola.
Poi si avvarrà
di qualche aiuto di percorso:
l'acqua, l'odore delle diverse situazioni
in cui si trova navigando,
guarda in qualche modo le stelle
e arriva anche lui dall'altra parte.
Che cosa ci racconta tutto questo?
Ci dice che bisogna trovare
non una separazione,
ma una integrazione fra queste due parti
che animano il nostro cervello,
quella che ci costituisce pienamente.
Certo, come musicista c'è un problema.
Il problema è che quando
qualcuno mi chiede:
- “Eh... lei che lavoro fa?”
- ”il musicista”
- “No, no, ma io intendevo
proprio come lavoro”
Ecco, come se fare il musicista
non fosse un lavoro.
In realtà è una specializzazione
umana straordinaria,
è quello a cui vorrei arrivare oggi.
Il messaggio importante che vorrei
che passasse dentro di voi è:
“Riappropriati del tuo essere musicista”
E in che modo scopriamo
di essere musicisti?
Perché abbiamo delle modalità
di esistenza,
quello che io chiamo
il “kit di sopravvivenza”
per stare in questo mondo fenomenico,
che sono assolutamente musicali.
Pensate ad esempio
a questa scena familiare,
che prelude forse ad un divorzio:
“Mario, porta fuori l'immondizia”;
“MARIO, PORTA FUORI L'IMMO....."
E Mario non ascoltava la moglie,
perché la moglie ha commesso un errore:
non è stata musicale nel dirgli
di portare fuori l'immondizia.
- “Ecco quando io parlo non mi ascolti,
devo ripetere le cose 50.000 volte”
No, Mario è semplicemente concentrato
a fare qualche cosa
e sta con la parte destra del cervello
assolutamente occupato.
Ma se lei avesse preso consapevolezza
del suo essere musicale,
cosa avrebbe fatto?
Quello che fa ogni musicista
quando compone un brano di musica:
avrebbe orientato le ripetizioni:
- “Mario porta fuori l'immondizia”
- “MARIO... PORTA FUORI L'IMMONDIZIA”.
State sicuri che Mario
ha già preso il pacchetto,
e lo sta portando fuori.
Non c'è bisogno di una terza volta.
Perché?
Perché la ripetizione orientata
è la rappresentazione di quello
che noi facciamo nell'esistenza.
Quando noi ripetiamo qualche cosa,
questo ci caratterizza
con due possibilità:
O ripetiamo per affermare sempre di più,
o ripetiamo per attenuare.
Un altro libro interessante era stato:
“Il pensiero laterale”,
che è proprio una possibilità
di sondare come funziona
la parte destra del cervello.
Molti di voi adesso si staranno chiedendo
che cosa c'entra questo con la musica...
Ma che cosa vi aspettavate?
Che io venissi qui
a suonarvi qualche cosa,
o a descrivervi
come funziona una sinfonia?
Ma se il mio obiettivo è quello
di dimostrare che voi siete la musica,
siamo in casa, stiamo parlando fra di noi
di qualche cosa che ci caratterizza!
Che cosa dice questo pensiero laterale?
Che un conto è stare nella linearità,
e pensare che le cose
sono una dopo l'altra,
quindi è il tempo fisico
che scorre inesorabile.
In un brano di musica,
pensate che l'ambizione
è quella di fare in modo di vivere
la fine contenuta nell'inizio.
È strabiliante questo pensiero.
Eppure...
che cosa è il navigatore
se non la rappresentazione di questo?
Che cosa fate quando voi
dovete andare in un posto
e mettete la destinazione?
Viene fuori tutto il tragitto.
Quindi che cosa avete rappresentata...
e che non vi crea ansia?
La fine, dove dovete andare,
contenuta nell'inizio.
Un'altra dimostrazione:
l'atto di pensiero.
Quando voi parlate,
si spera che abbiate già presente
dove volete arrivare.
E quindi che cosa dovrete fare?
Solo... dipanare nel tempo quel pensiero,
che ha già la fine
contenuta dentro di voi.
È la potenzialità che c'è nel seme,
che aspetta solo, attraverso un tragitto,
di arrivare alla fine.
E questo come si caratterizza
nella nostra esistenza?
Si caratterizza dal fatto
che le strutture narrative ci avvincono:
quando sentiamo raccontare una storia,
siamo assolutamente coinvolti.
Perché?
Perché sappiamo che cercherà di rispondere
a tre domande fondamentali,
che sono quelle che un brano di musica
rappresenta pienamente,
e per questo vi dico
“riappropriatevi della vostra capacità
di essere musicisti”,
perché tutti noi abbiamo questa capacità.
Che cosa fa un brano di musica?
Inizia; articolando arriverà
a un punto culminante;
e da quel punto culminante
andrà a finire.
Questo caratterizza
qualunque struttura narrativa.
È quello che oggi si tenta
di insegnare ai bambini,
quando devono svolgere un tema.
Gli si dice:
-”Prova ad immaginare una struttura,
dovrai esporre quello che accade.“
Pensate che c'è una forma musicale
che si chiama “Forma Sonata”,
che è caratterizzata da: Esposizione;
- poi dovrai sviluppare le idee
che hai messo in campo nell'Esposizione.
In musica si dice:
Esposizione; Sviluppo;
e poi dovrai andare
a concludere: Ripresa.
Caspita, ma allora i musicisti
ci possono dare una mano straordinaria
a comprendere come siamo fatti.
Ma noi quali prerequisiti abbiamo?
Allora, pensate: in quel Kit famoso
che abbiamo ricevuto,
abbiamo per esempio le "dinamiche"
che poi l'uomo ha trasposto
in questo straordinario mezzo
di comunicazione che è il suono.
Per esempio: un rumore “fortissimo”
ci mette in grande ansia.
Perché?
Si scatena dentro di noi
un'enorme tempesta adrenalinica.
Perché dobbiamo essere pronti a fuggire,
oppure restare nell'immobilità
per comprendere che cosa dobbiamo fare
nella situazione.
Allora che cosa è,
in musica, il “fortissimo”?
Quando un brano raggiunge il parossismo,
questo ha dentro di noi
una corrispondenza.
Poi c'è la relazione fra i suoni,
perché è questa la cosa fondamentale.
La grande confusione
del nostro tempo qual è?
Pensare che il suono sia la musica.
Non è così.
Il suono sono solo
vibrazioni regolari di corpi elastici.
Che cos'è che fa trasformare
il suono in musica?
La coscienza umana.
Pensate che straordinario pensiero
è questo,
per tutti coloro che pensano
che la musica stia morendo o sia morta.
Finché ci sarà un essere umano,
che è la musica,
la musica non potrà morire.
Ma ci vogliono persone che vi portino
a riacquisire questa consapevolezza.
Io dico sempre che ho
un atteggiamento socratico:
invece che pensare di portare qualcuno
a qualche cosa come [fosse] un vaso vuoto
che viene riempito da un vaso pieno
che gli trasferisce le informazioni,
preferisco, per questo bacino di utenza
che ci caratterizza da circa 2.000 anni,
dare più credito all'espressione:
“Γνῶθι σεαυτόν “, “nosce te ipsum”,
“conosci te stesso”.
Come dire:
“hai già tutto dentro, tiralo fuori.”
E Socrate, con la sua arte maieutica,
ci aiuta a fare proprio questo.
Ci vogliono degli operatori
sul campo però,
ci vogliono delle levatrici
che ci aiutino ad acquisire
questa consapevolezza.
Adesso proviamo a fare insieme
un esperimento.
Alzatevi in piedi
per un attimo, per favore,
e provate a rappresentare gestualmente
questi due suoni.
(Canta)
Vi sembra più consono
fare una cosa di questo tipo...
(Canta)
Dai gesti che ho visto fare,
mi sembra che forse
aderirete di più a questa:
(Canta)
Riaccomodatevi.
6 luglio 1789.
Danton, Marat, Robespierre.
Dicono: “Allora ragazzi,
siamo un po' in ansia.
- Per quando è fissata? - Per il 14.
(Risate)
- Eh, siamo malmessi...
Uno dei tre ha una intuizione e dice:
- Ragazzi, smuoveremo
un sacco di gente,
ma non abbiamo un inno!
Qui bisogna mettere in piedi
una audizione!
I musicisti sono molto soggetti a questo:
si va ad una audizione;
tu presenti il tuo materiale;
generalmente c'è una commissione
che poi dice:
”Va bene, grazie, si accomodi,
le faremo sapere.”
E che cosa è accaduto?
Si sono presentati vari [candidati].
Uno ha fatto così:
(Suona)
Loro hanno ascoltato e hanno detto:
Sì, oddio, potrebbe essere interessante...
Prego, le faremo sapere.
Certo, abbiamo un po' di fretta.
Poi è arrivato un altro e ha fatto così:
(Suona)
Beh, questa era un pochino meglio....
Se ne sono avvicendate varie.
Pensare ad un pianoforte nel 1789 è dura
ma comunque va bene lo stesso.
E poi è arrivato uno che ha fatto così:
(Suona)
(Canta) Ta - ta, ta - ta
Ah, ma allora c'è qualche cosa
che ci caratterizza davvero.
Noi abbiamo istintivamente
il senso della “estroversione”.
Vuol dire qualche cosa
che dal soggetto parte
e si proietta verso l'esterno
quando mettiamo in campo
questo intervallo,
che è quello fondante della musica
- è l'unico dato tecnico
che vi voglio lasciare -
L'intervallo di quinta,
vuol dire la distanza che separa
il primo suono dal secondo.
Questo.
(Suona l'intervallo di quinta)
(Suona "La Marsigliese")
Quindi scarnificando questo tema
da tutte le notine intorno...
C'è un metodo inventato da un giapponese
per portare la musica ai bambini.
Molti dei vostri figli probabilmente
avranno preso contatto con questo,
è il metodo Suzuki.
E uno dei brani caratterizzanti è questo:
(Suona la melodia)
(Suona l'intervallo)
Qui è accaduto anche
un fatto molto importante.
Quella struttura narrativa
che ha un momento
di proposta, di apertura,
poi deve trovare
la sua naturale compensazione.
Sarebbe stato terribile
avere una cosa di questo tipo:
(Suona)
Va bene, ma questa è una cosa
per addetti ai lavori,
è un tema molto complesso
che sicuramente su dei bambini
non avrà effetto!
Invece …
(Suona)
Come appaga la nostra necessità
di struttura narrativa!
Qualche cosa che si apra,
che raggiunga un punto culminante
e da quello torni indietro.
Allora che cosa cerco di lasciarvi,
oggi, come messaggio?
Noi siamo la musica,
riappropriamoci di questo.
Pensate al tempo di esecuzione
di un brano,
come noi riusciamo
a capirlo istintivamente.
Perché?
Perché abbiamo il ritmo dentro.
Abbiamo costantemente il cuore che batte
che ci dà una pulsazione.
Abbiamo i nostri passi che sono binari:
uno di appoggio e uno di rilassamento.
Infatti come critica ad un concerto,
che cosa succede?
Che è raro trovare qualcuno
che ascoltando una esecuzione dica:
certo, questa sera la modulazione
al secondo circolo delle quinte
non è stata ben soddisfatta,
debbo dire che anche le melodie
nella loro relazione...
No.
Quello che generalmente viene detto è:
Io non è che me ne intenda...
- sbagliato -
Però mi sembra
che non andavano insieme...
E poi c'è un'altra cosa importantissima:
La METRICA che all'interno di un discorso
deve venire fuori;
La metrica CHE all'interno di un discorso
La metrica che all'INTERNO di un discorso
deve venire fuori;
La metrica che all'interno di un DISCORSO
deve venire ...
Noi facciamo musica costantemente.
Riappropriatevi di questa capacità,
perché ciascuno di noi
è portatore di musica.
Bisogna riappropriarsi
di questa enorme risorsa
che ognuno di noi ha.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)